Mm,
when it comes to body language,
it's never an exact art and the things
I'm going to suggest that all
guidelines,
um,
but that said,
there are some certain things that as a
poker player,
I'll look for a.
and the most important thing is first of
all,
to get sort of a baseline of somebody.
It's impossible to tell whether the
behavior someone's showing is meaningful
or not if you don't know how they
naturally behave.
So the first thing I'll do when I sit
down at the table is look at what my
opponents are doing when they're not in
a hand,
you know,
are they naturally quite gregarious?
Are they confident when they interact
with the white dress or are they
naturally quite quiet and shy?
Um,
how do they,
how do they sit?
Are they,
are they naturally closed off,
are they very languishing,
that kind of thing.
And then once I've got an idea of that
baseline outside of a hand,
then I looked to see how they deviate
from that when they're actually in the
middle of playing or you know,
in a,
in a tense situation.
And in general,
what you want to look for in both poker,
but also when you have to say,
trying to figure out if someone's lying
is the comfort level.
Um,
if,
if there's sort of,
if they seem authentic,
like as a rule of thumb,
humans are actually quite good at
picking up a authenticity,
um,
or if someone's being disingenuous.
Uh,
so that's,
that's sort of the thing to look out
for.
And they're all some like classic
behaviors that I've noticed people do at
the table where they'll,
um,
they'll sort of make a point of if,
if you see them suddenly making a point
of making themselves bigger,
you know,
like where they're naturally setting
like this and now they're sort of
puffing up a,
that's more often than not sort of false
confidence at that they're trying to
show,
um,
you know,
most people do try to stay very
constant.
So if you've noticed sort of a,
like you really do notice a behavior
particularly against someone who seems
to play quite regularly to,
chances are they're,
they're aware of their behavior.
So they're probably trying to mislead
you.
But another rule of thumb I like to
follow is the first thing you learn as a
kid,
usually when you lie,
it is,
Oh,
lawyers won't look you in the eye.
So what do pick what the kids do to
overcompensate.
They'll,
they'll look you in the eye.
Um,
and similarly people are very aware of
their faces and you know,
this part of their body,
if they're trying to be dishonest,
but what they're not thinking about is
the rest of their body.
So the lower down on the body that
you're looking at,
the more reliable the information is.
So if you think about when you were
excited about something,
generally speaking,
you will bounce around and,
and sort of,
you can't keep still.
And you know,
that's like,
we call it happy feet in poker,
the feet are often the most reliable to
look at on your opponent because they
might be completely stoic in their face,
but their feet are bouncing around.
It's usually a sign that they have a
really strong hand.
But similarly,
if they're sort of smiling and chatty,
but their feet all of a sudden sort of
tuck themselves around the table,
around the chair legs,
something's up there.
So,
uh,
as a rule of thumb,
look for the rest of someone else's body
more than their face.
Um,
if you're trying to figure out if
they're telling you the truth or not.
Mm.